hallar el rango y el rango medio de la
siguiente serie de números y nos dan
estos números lo que el rango nos dice
esencialmente es que tan dispersos están
estos números y el modo en que se
calcula es simplemente tomando la
diferencia entre el mayor de estos
números y el menor así si nos fijamos en
el mayor de estos números lo voy a
redondear en magenta parís x el 94 que
es más grande que cualquier otro número
de aquí y de él queremos restar el más
pequeño de ellos que es el 65 hasta aquí
justo aquí el 65
entonces quiere restar 94 65 94 menos 60
son 34 y si le quitamos 5 lo que
obtenemos es 29 muy bien entonces cuanto
mayor es este número significa que se
extiende más la diferencia entre el
mayor y el menor número cuanto más
pequeño es significa que es más estrecho
el rango para usar la palabra propia de
estos números verdad el rango medio es
una forma de pensar a la tendencia
central hasta
grado por lo que el esto es porque el
rango medio lo que vamos a hacer con el
rango medio es tomar la el promedio la
media del mayor número y el menor número
entonces aquí tomamos la diferencia en
el caso anterior el rango medio vamos a
tomar el promedio de estos dos así
tendremos 94 más 65 es es la media
aritmética verdad dividimos entre 2 y
esto nos da 90 más 60 son 150 y más 45
son 159 159 y lo dividimos entre 2 esto
es igual a bueno 150 entre 2 son 75 9
entre dos son 4.5 así que esto nos da
79.5 esto fue una forma de pensar sobre
la media de estos números son la
tendencia central obviamente también
está la media aritmética la moda la
mediana pero bueno esto fue el rango y
el rango medio